let's take a closer look at some of the
of the operation inside ukraine and why
finland and sweden
feel the need to ramp up their security
defense and security analyst michael
clarke joins me now and and just looking
at the map as deborah was talking about
it is the the expanse of this border
that will trouble russia yes uh i mean
nato is 30 nations at the moment and
most of the nations that have joined
recently that were desperate to join
nato have been the small ones so the
last two members were montenegro and
north macedonia they had nothing in
military terms but sweden and finland
had an enormous amount because of their
maturity of states because of what they
represent sweden has been neutral since
1812 and has decided to change that
status finland's been neutral since
1945. and the finns when they mobilize
they mean it and their army is 200 000.
that would make it one of the biggest
armies in nato that's almost three times
bigger than the british army so when
swinland when sweden and finland joined
nato then nato's military capabilities
will increase quite a lot uh what about
what's actually going on inside ukraine
deborah referred to some of the fighting
there around kharkiv what what's going
on around donetsk in this particular
area yeah the the donbass offensive well
this big offensive is still building the
russians are still built bringing more
stuff in they're not really making much
progress except around pophasna but the
most interesting development is um
further north as deborah said around
carcu because the ukrainians are
counter-attacking to the north and the
east of kharkiv and that is really
complicating
russia's communications because their
communication runs from belgorod in
russia right through kharkiv to isiam
which is their northern anchor for this
big offensive that they're pushing
forward and the point is that these
counter attacks have put that
communication line within artillery
range and so what the ukrainians are
doing is they're forcing the russians to
sidestep eastwards to keep their
communications lines open it's a very
good example of ukraine's type of
defense to find a weak spot and go for
it and what they're doing is they're
exploiting a weak spot which is russia's
need to keep supplying from the belgard
area into isiam so they're pushing them
sideways which is not only good for
kharkiv because it gives it a bit of a
relief but it gives russia something to
worry about further north from where
they are making some gains around per
passenger in the south
and what about snake island that's one
of the places that we heard about right
back at the beginning of the war wasn't
it yes day one of the war snake island
the um the moskva
uh the flagship uh captured all of the
uh ukrainian troops on snake island who
told the mosque what it could do with
itself famously
and there is now another battle within a
battle going on at snake island because
the russians look as if they're trying
to reinforce it because we can see as
where snake island is
that can control the sea lions and the
air defenses of the whole this part of
the black sea the russians still are
blockading odessa and they will want to
actually continue to blockade odessa but
in order to reinforce snake island
they've got to bring their supplies from
sevastopol which is down in the south of
crimea a long distance about 180 miles
but snake island is only about 25 30
miles away from
ukraine itself so the ukrainians are
attacking these supplies that the
russians are trying to bring in so
already the russians have lost we know a
patrol ship they've lost a landing craft
there were rumors last week that the um
the makarev which is a
missile frigate had been damaged that's
unconfirmed the ukrainians claimed it
may or may not have happened we're not
sure but there is quite a battle going
on as the russians are trying to now
reinforce snake island and put something
valuable there and the ukrainians are in
quite a good position to stop them and
we've been intercepting some uh some
communications from the ships the
russian ships and they're they hate
these bairacta drones that are flying
around they call them chandeliers
because they're always above them and if
there's a biractor drone above them they
know that a bomb could land on them at
any moment it really frightens them